oh thank you very much and these are a few of them
Can't get it.
Can't quite get it.
Okay.
We were talking earlier about things that we're thankful to you for.
Thankful to you and... And these are a few of them.
We're thankful for your sense of humor.
Because it's got a...
We thank you for, to you, for teaching us a solution for relationships in pain.
And God has said, when I hear the word refuge, I think of Satipaññā.
It's my spiritual home.
Thank you very much.
Well, you've got to see it too, you see.
It's me, I'm sitting too far back really.
So, wait a few moments.
Well, I never...
I had a struggle with...
I had to make sense of Jesus, there's no doubt about that, because he was just so deeply buried in my heart.
And I struggled with that for a very long time.
And I had to come to some sort of understanding.
And I used to go, while I was in Sri Lanka, to see a friend who was a Hindu, but he had been a Catholic.
And it was funny, he kept talking about imagery, he kept talking about metaphor.
And I just wasn't getting it because in Theravada, everything is so scientific.
It's so, you know, one of these, ten of those.
There's not much theatre, there's not much poetry in Theravada as such.
And it just came upon me just all of a sudden, while I'm struggling with, you know, like,
the essential mystery of the body and the wine.
What's he trying to get across with that?
And it just, this is of course my own interpretation, that when he talks about this is my body and this is my blood,
Most people think, he's talking about Jesus, he's talking about the body, he's talking about, you know, in fact, even in the scriptures there, he says that to some people and they're disgusted with him.
I'm not, no, you know, it's like cannibalism.
But if you think about the Christ within, if you think about the Buddha, then ask yourself, what is the base of our Buddha nature?
What's its platform?
It's awareness, isn't it?
Sati.
What vivifies it?
It's that intuitive grasp of things.
So it's two sides of the same coin, the bread and wine, the awareness, and this intuitive grasp of things.
And that's what I think, and that's what I understood his teachings to be about.
And when I told this to the last Archbishop of Canterbury, he said, very interesting.
Rowan Williams, yeah, very interesting, he said.
So once that was sorted, it sort of, you know, it made sense to me what he was trying to do.
Because I think, frankly, he was trying to lift the Jews out of monotheism into something beyond that.
In the same way that Hinduism moves from Vishnu, Brahma, and who's the other fellow?
Vishnu, Brahma, and?
don't you know for heaven's sake trying to lift them out to Brahman so it's moving into that non-personal non-dualistic level and now you'll find teachers in Christianity that are teaching exactly that Cynthia Bourgeau Professor Cynthia Bourgeau you get her tapes and they're teaching Jesus they're calling him the wisdom Jesus and they're teaching him as a non-dualist teacher
Now, what happened, of course, was that Paul began to teach it to the empire.
Where were the empire?
They were in, what do they call it, before monotheism.
See, my brain's going there.
Polytheistic.
Polytheistic, right.
A polytheistic religion isn't about morality, it's about power.
You need the gods to do what they're supposed to do, so you offer them sacrifices and all that sort of stuff.
The shift towards that, towards monotheism, was a complete shift.
And it all happened 2,500 years ago, with the Buddha, with what was happening in the Upanishads, with Lao Tzu, with Socrates, and with Moses.
That was a huge shift in human consciousness.
But the Buddha sort of went just one step beyond.
Because there's no God, there's no personal God in Buddhism.
So he's already there at the pinnacle of non-dualism.
And Shankaracharya, I read a book called The Critical History of Indian Philosophy.
And according to this philosopher, Shankaracharya, the great teacher of Hinduism, actually took everything from Buddhism and made it into Hinduism and turned it into a non-dualistic religion.
That's how I struggle with it.
The monsters, monsters from Brighton.
Banty, you're the same age as Donald Trump.
What, you want me to commit suicide?
Bhante, if Samuel Beckett had ever written a Buddhist play, it would be the story of your life.
Thank you for a wonderful Dharma talk.
It was great.
Thank you.
I was rushed.
Noreen rushed me.
We listened all afternoon to that.
Sorry.
say that again we could have listened to a lot yeah yes well i was ready for all day actually so in the people's republic of brighton do the democratic approach rather than have a person um you've got all of us
Did you get that?
Rather than... Kind of.
Spokesperson.
Rather a spokesperson, yes, in fact, yeah.
So we were thinking, well, I think each of us were thinking earlier about what comes to mind when we think of you coming and teaching in Brighton.
For me, despite all, you know, I mean, of course, all the wonderful teachings that...
the Great Day Retreats, the Ship Street Gardens, the Dharma School.
But the thing that always comes to mind for me is trying to find new and unusual places to have a siesta after lunch.
Well, it's necessary.
I can't hear.
We've gone quiet.
We've lost you.
More recently it's been in a paper mache castle in the nursery room at the Dharma school surrounded by cuddly toys.
Happy birthday to Sarah as well.
Oh, I don't know if you can hear us.
Oh, come on.
It comes and goes.
You're going ta-da.
See you.
Ta-da.
Bye.
Are they seeing us?
Yeah, they're seeing us, yeah.
I wouldn't do it again.
I mean, it's been worthwhile.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's been worth the life, but I don't want to do it again under any circumstance.
I mean, what I'm hoping is that I come back, if I have to come back, with a bit more wisdom and I don't fall into these great big catastrophes.
So would you make three errors for this topic?
Absolutely.
Yeah, we talk about the Buddha's great, you know, the great enunciation, the great deliberation, the great determination.
Well, the only thing I ever did was the great black hole.
I was trying to get out of it.
But it was, you know, to me it was a miracle coming across the teaching.
It just lifted me out so quickly, you know, and grounded me.
Oh, no, I can't.
I can't remember at all.
But all I knew was that after I finished the book, and I've been trying to find it, but it's not there.
I'm going back to Burma, and I'll probably visit that monastery and see if I can find it.
But it's a strange thing, isn't it, that books find you.
People find you.
You know, it's weird, isn't it?
What was the title of the book?
I think it was just like, you know, teaching.
Something like that.
Well, it was the course of miracles, teaching, you know, the need for teaching, something like that.
It's only a thin little book.
Somebody had published this little collection.
It was really weird.
But I think it's surprising how all you've got to do is ask, isn't it?
Ask and the door should be open.
All that stuff, you know.
When you go to Japan, you said about Dogen was one of your draws.
Could you say any more about that?
Well, it's only because of that connection with Throssel.
And I've always wanted to visit the original monastery, because that's where Roshi Kennet, you know, if you want to read a biography of somebody living in a Zen monastery, training in a Zen monastery, read the biography of Roshi Kennet.
She was there for about, I don't know, three or four years, I think.
I think I'm right.
Did anybody else read it?
No?
And, I mean, it's a story of a half, because she's the only woman, you know, and she's coming across all these very male males.
And she's trained, yeah.
So I wanted to visit that just as a, really as a thanksgiving, you know, to go to a place and it had such an effect on me.
I'm taking Carl.
Yeah.
So when are you actually going?
April.
April 2nd for about three weeks.
Great.
I want to ask you,
Cheekily, when you saw this glowing tree, it wasn't your mate Dave's that you were... And I was still in contact with you.
No, actually, I skipped over this, but one of my...
I had two fears.
I had two hypochondriacal fears.
The first was going mad.
From about the age of 13, 14, I always felt I was going to go mad.
And that left me with that out-of-body experience.
The other one was paralysis.
And I went through this peculiar moment when, as I joined the order, my body was flinging itself all over the place.
I once woke up in the middle of the night with my body just... Ah, it's coming on.
Go.
That shouldn't have happened.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Look how many people.
I know.
That's Dublin.
That's Dublin, yeah.
It's Margaret.
Yes, that's Margaret.
It's her birthday, by the way.
It's her birthday.
You're slightly off screen there, Catherine.
Yeah.
I don't do that to change the lens.
Just to get the other hand.
Sorry about this.
That's Eugene, isn't it?
You'll get there, Eugene.
I believe in you, Eugene.
Wonderful.
Wonderful to see you all.
So you've got to speak, Hetal.
Bhante, just to wish you a happy birthday, and I was thinking that
what you said just now that you were in your not wanting to teach phase when you came here almost 30 years ago the day to teach that retreat in tala and for me it was a huge turning point so it was one of my blessings so thank you thank you yeah is that it but it was the almost
Can you hear us okay?
Does it sound okay?
Yeah, yeah, we can hear you.
But we missed that last bit.
Yeah, there's a lovely silence.
Okay.
Hi, this is Jimmy here.
I was also at that retreat, and I can remember quite, quite well.
And I just want to say that even though I had never been to Satyapanya, I still hold you as my teacher,
And I hope you don't take any umbrage at me not turning up.
I want to say as well, seriously, that the talk that you've given is such a real talk about a real person and not somebody stuck in kind of high pollution kind of philosophy or something.
And it makes such a difference that you can mix both.
both of them so well, and it's a joy to have you as a teacher.
I want to put emphasis on the word joy, grateful in the midst of all the confusion and despair.
So thanks very much.
Thank you.
And Bante, I thought I'd paralleled you a little bit.
in going to Trostle Hall as my first point of call for a Buddhist teaching.
I think I was possibly a few years behind you.
But I was struggling with their approach, which I found rather rigid and overly dogmatic and controlling.
So it was a great relief for me when I did a retreat with you and Ruat Adama in 87 in Birmingham.
It was quite a turning point for me, and it was a big turning point for our group when you came to Dublin the following year and moved in the more caravan way than the Zen way.
So thank you for your teaching over the years.
And I want to say that
Hearing the story about you rubbing cigarettes was so relieving.
On the first weekend, we didn't know we couldn't eat, so we rubbed bananas in the kitchen.
I never told you that.
I'm getting it off my chest.
Absolutely.
so we just uh birthday again and i think it's gone and um uh i just want to wish you all wish you happy birthday from all of us and look forward to uh teachings in the future thank you thank you take care thank you
Where was I before that interruption?
Ah, it's gone.
You were talking about the woman who had gone to a monastery where she was the only woman.
Oh, yeah, that's Roshi Kennet.
Yeah, but I don't know what in context.
It's part of being 70.
I can't remember a thing.
It's great.
Every moment is new.
Who are you again?
What are your hopes for the next 10 years?
Sorry?
That I continue to live.
I think I need a bit more time to...
I mean, what I would like is a halo of teachers.
Do you like that?
A halo of teachers to be established here.
Seven or eight of them.
So that the place just has that background of good teachers, you see.
At the moment we have three.
So there's Carl, Aya and Hus.
Put your hand up, Hus, please.
There we are, you see.
So it'd be nice to have that, you see.
And hopefully to find a way to run this place which doesn't depend on me.
That's my target for the next five years.
And then I'll disappear.
Yeah, that would be my hope anyway.
I was going to say disappear in what respect, as in go somewhere else, as in just... No, just no.
I don't think...
I'll only disappear when it's time to go.
I'm wondering about the... You talked before about Gaia House and the dilemma of becoming a layperson and disrobing, and it's quite a new... Well, I suppose we think of
monks within a group and you've chosen to be on your own i just wonder about your commitment to being in robes and just sticking with the monastic order despite but not being with other people yeah yeah yeah um no that's true lone monks are known you don't not you know you will get monks who are quite happy to be on their own um it's not a choice it's just the way i've ended up
There are no Western monks that I was involved with in Sri Lanka who could have come over with me.
There just weren't any.
That's the end of it.
So I was basically on my own from the beginning, you see.
It would have been nice to have had a partner or somebody to run the place, you know, somebody whom you're compatible with.
You have to remember that just because you're a monk doesn't mean you like the person.
It's a varied community.
But there have been many times throughout the 30 years, this is my 30th year, where I've wanted to leave.
There was one point where I was going to bed saying, right, tomorrow that's it, we'll get out, we'll do something useful.
And I'd wake up in the morning and I'd say, well, God, I'll give you just one more day.
And in the end I just had to laugh.
Now, every time I came to this point of wanting to leave, I couldn't think of anything at all in society that attracted me.
I went through the whole job.
And I usually ended up with a fantasy of stacking shelves and going back to the garret and doing my meditation.
So I said, well, I can do that without stacking shelves.
So I never left.
Every time that, you know, there were times when I was very close.
One of them was at the end of that escapade up in North London.
I mean, that was an obvious time where, you know, I didn't know where to go.
There was nowhere, but I just, there was nothing.
I just ended up faffing about.
What about the robes?
What about the actual... Robes?
Well, I'm stuck with the colour.
I mean, I'd love to wear blue.
You know, pink.
I'd love to wear pink.
You look pink.
Pink-like.
What do you mean by the robes?
Well, I suppose, why not just become a layperson?
Oh, I see.
Ah.
Oh, very good.
Hello.
Hello, greetings from Westbury.
Hooray!
Very good.
How are you?
We have one teenager here in pyjamas, Fante.
Is that okay if she appears?
Alicia.
She's wearing pyjamas.
Yes, that's all right.
Thank you for giving your birthday greetings.
Oh, very good.
We wanted to show you the birthday cake that we'll be celebrating your birthday with.
Oh, Fante.
So we're just...
Maybe bring it a little bit closer.
You'll be eating your words very soon, Bente.
So the cards that we sent based on some of the memories that we have from visiting.
I just wanted to share one little story that we still find amusing.
And it was the time that we climbed up a mountain.
And for those of you who don't know where it is, it's a mountain of spiritual significance here in West Kerry.
and named after St. Brandon the Navigator, who went to the shores to America.
So a few years ago, we hiked up with Bhante right at the top where there's a beautiful Catholic cross and an inscription and a little cairn of stones.
So Bhante decided that at the top of the mountain on a clear blue sky day, very calm, that he would chant.
So he sat in the little cairn and he began his chant, his Pally chant, which we joined in, and then suddenly this wind whipped up, started blowing around us at the top of the mountain, and Bhante put up his hands and he said, the wrath of St. Brendan is upon you.
So that's one of the memories we have from one of your visits here to us, Bhante.
Thank you.
anything else anything uh bandy uh john here just to uh wish you a happy birthday thank you that's your first 10-day retreat uh you uh performed in in the pub view hostel for 20 years ago so uh you've gone from strength to strength and uh we thank you for your inspiration
Thank you very much.
Keep the cake.
I'm coming.
If we could keep you in peace, we would, but we'll send you photos of it.
We're just going to light the candles now and sing you out from West Kerry.
Thank you very much.
you know come on we're going to sing it in irish fenty happy birthday to you in irish you've had it in pali and you're getting the gaelic version now
I'll eat the head.
What's your funniest teaching experience?
Funniest teaching experience?
Can't think of any.
What do you mean by funniest teaching experience?
Actually, you've got a question to answer as well.
You answer her question.
That was about the robes.
See, I remembered.
The robes.
Why don't I?
Oh, I see.
Well, the robes are a guardian, really.
Because, you know, you have to behave in a certain way when you walk around in robes.
But it's just, you just get used to it.
I haven't even thought about that, really.
The question was about, you know, other than that, you know, have you thought about being a Dharma teacher, but as a layperson?
Oh, yeah.
That's what I thought, yeah, but it doesn't attract me because...
Dharma teachers, they get support, but remember they've got massive overheads.
Sometimes they have children, they have cars to run, all that sort of stuff.
Being a monk really releases me from all that sort of baggage.
You shouldn't call it baggage really, you should call it delight.
Releases me from the delight of all my life.
So that my, you know, once I've got my laptop and stuff like that, that's it.
If I left, it would, I don't know, it just doesn't attract me.
I mean, I'm conditioned now.
It takes such a long time to recondition yourself.
I just feel comfortable in the roads.
It's as simple as that.
And I haven't got long to go anyway.
That's the point that you... Ah!
Hello.
Ah, hello Mike.
Our building consultant.
Upon whom we are dependent.
Hi.
Hi Vandy.
Well, happy birthday.
Thank you.
I'm getting distracted here.
I've got two things going on at once.
There seems to be a delay on the...
Can you hear me?
Yes, yes.
Ah, well, happy birthday.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for all the teachings you gave me over the years that we've been building together.
There was one incident that actually typifies you, which you probably actually forgot, but we were away in Suffolk
and we went to a church.
And whilst we were wandering around, the Virgin came out and gave us a guided tour.
And there was a chap came into the church who was distressed, didn't have any money to get home, was obviously in an incredibly bad way.
Before the verger could actually say anything, you'd put your hand in your pocket and gave the guy five quid.
And the verger was so blown away, he couldn't believe your generosity and your instant kindness.
And that's a memory that sticks with me when I think of most of the stuff.
Thank you very much, mate.
It was a very...
generous moment, and it just typified your embodying loving-kindness.
Really a nice moment.
Yeah, that was a good moment I had.
Well, we all love them sometimes.
Exactly that.
Take care.
Well, I hope there's another 70 years worth of
That is influence, if not presence, in the South Canyon.
Certainly the building will last another 70 years.
Yes.
I'll see you Thursday.
It's coming up to check it out.
A funny teaching moment, I can't think.
Pam?
This is sort of related to that.
I've known you for a really long time.
40 years, probably.
Yes.
And you always were really, really, really funny and I think you're still really funny.
And so do lots of people who really appreciate your sense of humour.
How important do you think a sense of humour is in the spiritual life?
Not just yours, but everybody's spiritual life.
Do you think that a sense of humour has a place?
Erm...
Well, definitely it's catching the irony, isn't it?
It's catching the paradox, seeing the paradox.
Remember in Zen Buddhism, once you break through the delusion, there's this great guffaw, this great laugh that it's all been this stupid mistake.
Now you've messed up.
Oh, hello.
Ricardo, come in.
Is that over now, is it?
Ah, that's it.
Fantastic.
Thank you very much.
So, yes, how are we doing for time?
Tea time, is it?
No, there's stuff to do, yeah.
Oh.
So, yes, humour.
I'd like to take this opportunity to present you with a cheque, quite a large cheque.
This is donations, as you know, from all of the Sangha.
A very generous offer has been made to round up what was donated to give us this figure.
of 7,070 pounds and 70 pence.
My goodness, look at that.
70, 70, 70.
That's not bad, is it?
Yeah, I'm particularly relieved because it means I can get a return ticket.
That's wonderful.
Thank you.
Bo-dee-dump.
No.
No, it's not.
Bo-dee-dump.
No, no, I'm joking.
Oh, you're joking.
Kill that man.
Nor is that me also to remind us that we've got other groups sitting around the world.
We don't know exactly how many people have been tuning into the broadcast, but we will find out.
But there's Ursula in Liverpool, the group there.
That's right.
Sandra and Gianni are in Italy who are on retreat at the moment, but they send us good wishes in spirit.
And Michelle in Switzerland and the group there.
And Marina at Terre de Ville in France.
Ah, Marina.
There we are.
Thank you.
Over to you.
Oh, look at that.
Thank you, he's high.
So we wanted to present you this little Parinirvana Buddha as a symbol of the big Parinirvana Buddha that unfortunately couldn't get here in time for your birthday.
And Richard's son Simon bought it in Sri Lanka.
Did he?
Oh, right.
He's happy, isn't he?
He posted it.
He's very happy, look.
He chose one.
You get a crick in the neck if you stay like that.
Thank you very much.
I'll put that here.
And we also wanted to give you this little book for you to read on your pilgrimage.
It's the 17th century haiku poet's account of his own pilgrimage in Japan.
Apparently he also wanted to go all his life on a pilgrimage and managed to get round to it later in life.
That's lovely, thank you.
Sadhu!
That sounds a bit like me.
So, Andy, I was glad to see you got at least one birthday card through the post, because otherwise you might have been a little bit disappointed that we'd forgotten you.
But what happened was we asked everyone to send their birthday cards to Dea and Richard, who then bound them up into that lovely book.
Yeah, that's right.
So...
What we asked people to do was to maybe find a photo or a quotation or something that represented however you would judge their lives over these past years and I think you will find that there are really
very beautiful expressions of gratitude and appreciation there and friendship and also some attempts to illustrate the Dhamma which might give you a little bit of a fright.
Who knows?
Who knows what?
But so your great gift to us has been to really bring the Dhamma alive in your teachings and your interactions so that we thought for your birthday you might like to just change a magazine.
and let what you have given out to us over the years be reflected back.
And also, anyway, we really enjoyed approaching the Dhamma this way, you know, trying to find pictures that would illustrate things like Luca and Anatta and so on.
So if you can enjoy reading through it as much as we enjoyed putting it together, we will be very happy.
If you thought that looked like quite a few cards, we've got a few more here for you.
This is another book that we put together in a portrait format.
Oh, that's lovely.
And in this box here are some more cards and a scroll from Sister Ruth.
Oh, Sister Ruth.
And I think you'll find that that's obviously from the group who made the cake.
LAUGHTER
It looks like Simpsons.
Thank you so much.
It's a lovely box too.
It does, doesn't it?
That's disgusting.
Thank you so much.
Oh, heavens, more.
Happy birthday, Banty.
Thank you, Pam.
Very important person in my life.
when we were young young and carefree yes in those happy days in Birmingham and I wasn't going to say anything so it's written so I think I'll just write uh read what I so this these two pictures you'll see what they are you know what they are because you said they were okay so the story is that we were traveling around Malaysia
and went to a Buddhist centre, I think it was in Malacca, and explained Satipanya.
And the very nice woman there, the nun, said, you must have these two pictures on very thin rice paper.
Now, we were going around Malaysia with small backpacks, two weeks.
New Zealand, five weeks.
Cambodia, Bangkok.
So these
these pictures have been around the world eventually got them back home to Stroud brought them to you to see if you'd like them for your birthday and you said yes so they went back to Stroud to be framed and now they're here so with lots of love from me Paul and Jack and Rosie fantastic thank you can I open it yeah you certainly can there we are right okay well let's see what we can do here
It must be.
You can't just rip it off, can you?
Not that they've spent so much time putting it together.
I think I can slip it out, actually, from there.
To...
Hey, aren't they beautiful?
I can't believe that we traveled around with them.
We travel light, small day packs for 12 weeks.
And we actually managed to get them here without any tears.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much.
Pleasure.
Oh, my goodness.
Sukhamyatadivasete Sukhamyatadivasete Sukhamyatadivasete Sukhamyatadivasete Sukhamyatadivasete
Fantastic!
Fantastic, thank you so much.
That's it now.
I've just got to say something.
Divert the attention away from you, Bente, for just one minute.
And just say something on behalf of the Settipendi trustees, which is to...
mark and thank everybody for the fantastic effort that's gone into this day and how it's worked so well um firstly i'd like to thank uh charles and heather pete and mark are here today thank you very much it's been fantastic
also understand that uh paul could have been here but he isn't he's unwell and just to send our best wishes to him and thanks to him as well um and then to thank you of course thank uh the satipani singer which has been fantastic today couldn't work without you and thank you very much and then to say that behind every great effort and event there's always a committee and uh we had these uh
the Birthday Celebration Committee, I think they call it.
Satipanya Celebration Committee.
And I'd particularly just like to thank Aya, thank Noreen, Sarah, Daya, and Richard, and Mark the voice.
And thank you very much for all your help and well done.
And for anybody out there in the world who hasn't made a donation yet, the lines are still open until midnight tonight.
They're on PayPal.
So can we say that people who stay behind can have a piece of my cake?
Yes.
Yeah?
I'm not supposed to eat it by myself, am I?
It's fantastic.
Oh, my goodness.
Gwen made the cake.
That's what you call a fruitcake.
That is a fruitcake.
Very good.
Matthew, do you want to tell people at all whether or not they're going to come back after two years?
Would you say goodbye now?
I didn't feel people had any further questions or anything.
I saw them on your 80th birthday party.
Can I just interject something?
There is a small extra gift from the local Satapanya group in 1980.
And then come back?
No, and leave it outside.
So if we go for tea, it could be there.
You might be able to see it.
Oh, very good.
Very good, let's go for tea.
You always wanted a dog, didn't you?
Oh, I do not want a dog.